نعم اعلنت القوات المسلحه الاعلام العسكري
عن هذه المواجهات اللي بتتم على الحدود
الاردنيه الشماليه مع سوريا الشقيقه للاسف
هذه نتيجه للفوضى الموجوده والفراغ في
السلطه اللي بؤدي الى نمو ووجود وسيطره
بعض الميليشيات والجماعات التي تقود حربا
اقليميه وتصدر المخدرات للاردن وتريد ان
تصدرها ل دول الخليج والدول العربيه ما
وراء الاردن هو الهدف والاردن ايضا هو
الهدف بالنسبه ل
القائمين على
عمليه تصدير المخدرات وتهريبها هذه
اشكاليه كبرى ليست فقط مشكله اردنيه
واشكاليه اردنيه بقدر ما هي ايضا مشكله
اقليميه ومشكله جزء من الصراع اللي بتقو
هذه المليشيات المدعومه من قوى اقليميه
للاسف تستهدف استقرار وامن الاردن الاردن
من عام 2022 بدايته اعلن عن تغيير قواعد
الاشتباك وكان في هناك قتلى وخسائر فاتحه
في صفوف المهربين وقبل اسبوع كان في
استشهاد احد منسوبي القوات المسلحه
الاردنيه منسوبي الحدود وهذا كان نتيجه
استغلال القائمين على عمليه التهريب
للظروف الجويه والمناخيه اللي بيكثر فيها
الضباب في
فترات متاخره من الليل الى الفجر وبيستغل
ه الفتره حتى يقوموا بعمليات التهريب
ويستخدموا
تقنيات كبيره والفتره الاخيره صاروا ياتوا
كجماعات ويخوضوا اشتباكات مع قوات حرس
الحدود ما يؤدي الى خسائر ولكن في النهايه
الاردن مصر على هذه الحرب ومصر على اجتثاث
مصره على مقاومتها لانها حرب عابره وحرب
تستهدف بنيه وقوى المجتمع الاردني ولا
هواده في
مواجهتها